all right and the game just started so
that's why we we had to cut that
interview a bit earlier you guys night
at three buy chocolate bars and actually
he car do you mind repeating the
percentage I was too busy trying to find
the game I well I just made a prediction
I said it's a hundred percent that
chokha bars gonna win because slicker he
had some issues with with his coach Oh
was it with Hans after after the firing
Wow okay anyway yeah I just I feel like
there might be some some bad karma some
someone has taken a lot of owls even if
they're not playing the event I I have a
feeling they might take another owl oh
it's like her blood or so I'll move one
I told you guys this is a blender I'll
move one slicker see this guy just
brings all the bad luck he's slickers
very lucky that she didn't take the pawn
cuz she could have taken the pawn and
moved one and she would have been way
ahead
I think flicker realizes that he got a
little bit lucky there but it's it's
it's definitely a game well it seems
like she was just remembering her system
with d39 f pg3 instead of trying to look
for alternative moves here right exactly
yeah certainly I helped her with this
setup so I gave her some basic
preparation in terms of how to play how
to play this opening I think so far it's
pretty good um one thing that I don't
like what's what's liquor has done is
he's pushed his pawn to e5 in this pawn
to d6 the same setup that he did against
forsen in the previous game so I I don't
like the setup per se but I think it's
still it's the game still very much in
the balance right and we see that this
is actually very this is a very ekari
system you know how to play these
quickly very well and you have had such
success with your coaching are there any
opening traps you prepared chocolate
bars for in this one
um not specifically no I think what I
would say is she should bring the night
out and push the pawn in the center of
the board so far I do like everything
that she has done I did not show her the
specific setup but I do I do think she
has a basic understanding what the idea
is and I think slicker as well as trying
to play some basic development following
the basic development principles and and
so I
I like I like what both of them have
done so far however I saw slicker
hovering over Jesus with the pond that
however would not do this because if I
go here and I bring my queen here take
it
he takes it I can take it okay I'm doing
that I'm doing it I'm doing it because I
could go up in and bully this as well
you know so he can retreat because she's
acting more of a bully in it
so I don't know what doing get me have I
lost something I don't give up I don't
care right retreat so I'm gonna move
this up here and move this hair right
oh no but then she could take me with
the horse you see now that's the point
where I need to chill you know okay I
got this I got this I ain't gonna let
the 1 6 1 down trust me boys I wish I
could look at the chart let me fake
reading messages your slicker I see that
bro you're doing good um so come one of
your longtime subs bro if you win this
game I'm giving you 50 gifted subs Pro a
generous for your generous man I respect
that spike oh she moved I didn't know
that all right okay don't just take this
disc Yanni think bro Fink was that point
it was there to do you know cuz I need
to protect my queen in it so if I move
my queen okay yeah she always liked him
she taught me duel a defense mechanism
yeah cuz look her right here yeah she
tried to be a bit smart yeah but she
don't know what she doing here glad I
you know what I I have also said this I
kept my what did happen last time when I
played against Ludwig I destroyed him
strong for style all right wait but this
is very dangerous remember this if I'm
stupid
I will move something to read I ain't
stupid unless I can move this here to
show that there's remorse
but then that's too greedy I'll move
this another switches here so I got the
rook closer so I can defend all this
monk parts here so you know she's taking
her time so we boss over you know but
two peas no not this one
rather be alright I think he was
switching over to his youtube there I
mean he has very high energy but I like
the way he's able to think out loud I do
too it but actually he's in quite a bit
of trouble in this opening stage because
he's developed these pieces but his King
is gonna be very open down on this long
diagonal in the next couple of moves so
I'm kind of concerned for slicker
actually yeah I don't know yeah his
still in the center of the board and if
he castles and the bishop is going to be
looking very menacing and it is too
short it is too long for him to try to
castle on the Kings side because he's
enough to get his dark squared bishop so
it's at least three rooms away right
exactly and I think if she takes with
the Queen here she'll be doing very very
well tell you what the bishop is also
completely fine as well it just have to
push the pawns in the center here I
think so right because if she would have
taken with the Queen and he would have
castled so quickly she could have almost
made it now there's a really nice tactic
here with Bishop takes b7 and Queen f3
but again I don't think she's gonna play
it she's probably gonna push the pawn
I'm guessing to e4 or push the pot to d4
I'm just highlighting that for you yeah
I think pushing the pawn is also very
intuitive here she can at least continue
a beautiful move attacking the bishop
now the bishop can go to III don't like
problem with this is that she's blocking
her LightSquared bishop from possible
attacks on the key right at the same
time however you can push the pawn in
the center you can bring this Darce for
a bishop out so I really do like the
position I do I do the next level moves
are gonna be critical for both players
however when I look at the time clock
the timer choke of Baris is eight
minutes and slicker has 659 so it's
already he's already a minute behind oh
no oh oh no he Carly your
did you say a hundred percent chance for
chocolate bars here yeah I mean what is
liquor doing well I think this is a
great moment to see what chocolate bars
is saying sure I get a bishop and a
horse and he gets one Bishop right go
what's my next move ah I think if I go
here then he takes then I take well
let's say this does I was loading her
stream to hear her and now I realize
[Music]
yeah she's doing very very well here I
think we should watch slickers I want to
see what his reaction is well I think
we'll get that on the production end and
while we wait she's now up a full-piece
slicker down I swear you okay I can't be
us if she takes this I really can't be
bothered mom if I move this here she
checked me to the but why try and take
me I take it if she takes it I'll take
it back no can I do what can she do she
can go here but then I can't I can take
it back
I'll still win this trust me this girl
this girl talks wait she's Canadian hold
on Conner I didn't know she was Canadian
oh my god then she has a brain she has a
chance I believe in him I never leave as
you know she's Canadian so I take that
bug okay listen I I bought a left
testicle thing I'm not gonna sell it am
I gonna sell my left testicle if I lose
so you know there might be a chance I
could lose this boat oh my god why's she
doing here
[Music]
right
while we stood mute that was potentially
one of the most wasted moves I've ever
seen in my entire career yeah it's
really well yeah so I think seeing that
she has to retreat the bishop is very
intuitive I would have liked Bishop d2 a
lot better or Bishop III because now she
doesn't have to redevelop for Bishop one
more time so she this is a tempo here
unfortunately right exactly I mean I
still think the game is very much up in
the air it's not really clear who's
who's better necessarily I think it's
gonna come down to the plants but the
problem for slicker is that he's behind
on the poor he's also behind on the
clock and he's and I mean I think in
general he's not feeling overly
confident put the bishop on e7 which I
guess is a good sign but then he's gonna
have to eventually push one of his pawns
if he wants to open up again you can't
move his Bishop on e7 right away because
then maybe g7 is hanging it's a very
awkward development for the black pieces
here on top of being down tonight
right I mean I I think he's what he's
got to do is try to attack towards the
white king okay i-4 is a very good move
I like this move - okay so now so now
sluggers trying to attack towards the
king he's got a rook and he's got a
queen but still it still is still tricky
so now you have to move the Queen back
of course not not to blunder your queen
and if slicker ends up taking on f4 then
she can take back with the bishop and
develop her piece although then slicker
might go for a move like g5 with a tempo
and actually get some type of counter
play with a King side attack yeah I
think this is gonna this is still very
very tricky for both sides in the coming
moves but I do like the position so far
I think I mean III think it's still very
unclear but III Babar's is definitely
better and if she doesn't make any major
blunder
I think that she should win the scheme
because of the position and the timer
situation however this is why you play
the game because it's not over until
it's over and I I do expect there to be
blunders by both players going forward I
don't think we're gonna see correct
moves for both players just just for the
rest of the game and that being said so
slicker being down at peace do you think
the best idea for him is to just go for
the riskier play and just try to go for
her King even if he has less pieces yeah
I mean certainly I guess the real
question is did it did and this is not
me trying to be be funny but it's
whether his coach Hans actually showed
him any ideas of like how to attack
towards the King with pieces or not if
Hans showed him something basic along
those lines I think he can probably put
two and two together and try to attack
um if he didn't though I think I mean
it's a weird structure because it not
many people put these put their pawn in
front of the King like this so he was
hovering over the H pond for a while but
it seems like he went for d5 instead
which is well he's giving another pawn
for free in order to bring his bishop
into the game which is actually a pretty
decent idea because his Bishop was out
of place at least he understands that
mm-hmm right so he's still he's still in
the game I think a lot comes down to
whether chocobos remembers to develop
her Bishop and her rook this is the only
issue she has her the bishop and the
rook are undeveloped they're still in
their original squares and you need to
bring them into the game right
so after a move like Bishop c5 if she
plays Bishop e3 I'll be very confident
in her position because she's trading
off she's simplifying and then she'll be
able to get her rook activated as well
exactly so I mean thus far she's played
she's played a very good game I like her
position everything she's done for the
most part has been pretty pretty precise
okay now Bishop e3 is the moment of
truth and it's not an easy move to find
here necessarily um because she might
just reply directly to the threat and
move her King right right exactly if she
plays Bishop III I really think she's
gonna win this game just cuz that where
the pawns are in relation to the Queens
and the rooks I think she's she's in
very good shape so that's where this is
really the question is whether she
blocks with the bishop or not well we're
gonna take a listen to chocolate bars
and see if she's
play bishop or three and if he takes it
we're just trading so I kind of like
this instead of putting my minion up
because if I do this he just eats and I
have no answer but if I do this he comes
down I take this and then we're good yes
I don't really want to move my queen I
want to trade I want to get rid of his
units so I have less things to think
about because I am ahead right now very
nice
that was a nice find I'm impressed with
that
so I echo your sentiment that now I
think she has very good chances what I
would like to see slicker do here is
bring the queen up to e7 and at least
try to take back with a queen well my my
dad southern is right now go for that
desperado last attempt to try and blow
up in her King side yeah exactly the
Queen e7 is very hard to find here I
just feel like the position stuff itself
is just not very it's not conducive
because of how closes closes like there
aren't open lines and I found most of
and most of the players who are new to
the game if they don't really see the
movement of the rooks specifically and
opening these files that easily so I
think because when I look at where the
pawns are and the piece placement you
just don't you don't have open lines for
the rooks with a queen so in terms of
slicker like it's just hard to come up
with the concepts here right and the
problem with b6 is now slickers King if
she decides to take the bishop is the
one that's going to get even weaker on
top of having a poor pawn structure
right exactly well so I guess if your
slicker here you're just waiting and
you're you're trying to survive he's
also lower on the clock situation for
why you've seen enough choco bards that
she get into time pressure at all yeah
she does get a time pressure pretty
frequently I would say so that certainly
is an issue but as long as she stays
ahead on the clock by about 30 seconds
to one minute I think the pressure is
always gonna be on slicker so Rick ad
one maybe not the best move of course
but the
one good thing is slicker played Bishop
to b4 and I do remember when I was
helping helping choco bars out the one
she one thing she remembered is to push
push pawns on the side of the board to
remove the pen so I am expecting her to
play a three here base on base on based
on what I saw before all right well we
are going to switch to slicker stream
now sure
oh my god
just get up to me okay just need to
think a premie of my head why did she
move that okay I was a silly me if that
was like pointless right all I need to
do if I could get this here if I could
get my queen up there right and check me
you'll be checkmate on over this she can
take me there man just do something bro
come on I need to think all I want to do
is Chuck me if I go here it should go to
him but she could move there so you see
that's not checkmate unless unless I go
there and then she moves on and then I
leave this here and should be she's got
to move the trimers time is really an
issue here my first deal or what I would
do which is never gonna happen
but what if I move this here and then I
take this or this
no but then she could take me with that
and then what and then I could take wait
hold on miss quick what did I just do
what did I just do miss click miss click
oh my gosh okay but I mean he's okay
let's see what happens
my name is I could do this Wow okay
risking risk it for the biscuit risk as
much do y'all know tell me right right
so now I mean I guess the question is
can you play to see if she sees the
swing check with the knight move she'll
be winning I don't know unique night
making the check with the Queen it's
also kind of hard to find good moves
though I mean it's hard to find moves it
that for beginners make sense logically
here for both sides so I have feeling
both players gonna be getting very low
on the time in this game I think this
might be decided by by by time yeah
that's fair and I mean this is actually
a moment where choco bars can go in for
King side attack if she sees a move like
Queen a six track it's a noose over the
pawn is hanging but the more natural
move to defend the pawn with King b8
might actually lose after Knight b5
right right so so yeah so she's hovering
over the Queen I see and now the night I
mean she just got a move she just has to
make moves fast
yeah she moves quickly she doesn't have
to worry about the perfect line here cuz
if she gets under a minute on the clock
I will be worried that she might end up
making blunders right yeah I mean I
think both players are very likely to
make serious blunders here I think
whoever has more time it's probably
gonna be the winner here I think whoever
has more time will win that's my
prediction
well that's slicker so far even though
he's down a piece you think he's the
favorite now I I think every move it
hinges upon but whoever it does they
both have to make moves quicker and if
one player goes and uses 30 seconds or a
minute on one of these moves they're
probably gonna lose so it's very
critical here that that um especially
for choco bars that she moves fast
she's getting very low on time I would
love to see moves like c4 and c5 here
for her or just shifting right there's a
lot of new she can make and most of them
are okay the only thing I guess she does
have to be careful about is the h4 and
then taking on g3 and trying to open
right exactly but I mean she's gotta
move she just has to make moves here oh
that's tears they shouldn't be opening
up her King side right exactly yeah
this is very dangerous but she this is
actually I noticed was when she got
really low on time against not long time
but when she started moving really fast
against NIMH but this is also not bad
because it's two rooks in a bishop
against two rooks so even though this is
not the best move the odds of getting
checkmated get reduced significantly
because you have because the material is
less so she's got to make a move here
pretty quickly actually only I want to
get under one minute acceptable moves
like he can make sure rook move she can
make a pawn move which she does c4 is a
very nice note here yeah both both
players I this is gonna this game is I
I'm gonna say that I think this game
might rival the the the epic epic one
between foosley and neat he'll
potentially oh that would give me so
many hard a taxi car alright we're gonna
take a listen in slicker stream again no
there's no potential fraud fraud you'll
arrest you know so let me just you know
play very safe you know I'm not in no
rush oh she said she thought I would do
this 9 that Dom you know oh it should I
should let you let you let you let you
let you let you let you let you actually
you're watching you boys listen there's
been misconceptions of me seen I would
witness oh my can be forward yeah oh no
no no no don't do that because then she
can be done to do this yeah yeah so so
very very hard to predict what's gonna
happen
I need time okay well he didn't get
forked so that's a good sign
he almost would have fallen for f6 yeah
I mean okay so he takes takes with the
rook
they're equal all the time situation now
it's gonna do it I could take this but
she's gonna retrieve some lovely two
situation let's see if she can win this
one 24 I'm gonna do this fast let go now
let go now risk it risk it chat let go
now
uh wait which I think she could take
this but she has to have to make moves
with rack to make quick I need to
threaten her oh wait she's thinking way
too awesome leave something apart save
there wait that's a good move nice not
leave now if she sees this oh I like
that like that like that like that like
that seek I swear let me think
he should protect his pawn at this point
if he can push that's five here then
he's in much better shape don't don't
give up the rock
oh I'll be stupid what am i doing that
get trade no it's not worth for my talk
about okay now she'd move move the best
horse but both players but flicker time
you got a move that you got a move stop
stop I was a jingle this trip because of
this yes oh dear Lord Almighty
dear Lord Almighty this is worrying no
is worrying me this game is gonna be
very very tricky okay then we do know we
do know well are you doing no no you
take the dancing later you have no time
slicker yeah this is this is gonna be it
this gonna be whoever whoever it gets to
long time I mean I think basically is
what's gonna happen this is okay
yeah I have no idea who's gonna end up
winning this game um slicker up up a
pond but down 15 seconds
slicker did mr. checkmated won by the
way you saw the meat right augs Andrew
oh I was a rookie 7 checkmate there was
a rook d7 checkmate with the rook on g2
ok well anyway yeah ok I mean I have no
idea what's gonna happen here because
she can take if she takes the pawn with
the rook I think this will be a draw
okay rook takes pawn rook takes pawn
here and it will be a draw I think
although honestly there's foot there
three results as possible I really am
not just any huge I'm just gonna watch
this because anything can happen here
literally anything okay so you have to
move the king slickers audio is just is
just distracting me it's hilarious ECAR
but I'm getting very distracted
okay so now you have to take the rook
okay oh there might be a sec right here
right there might be a background check
for oh don't take on e4 don't take on
what she didn't see it the first time so
I would be hard for me to believe that
she sees it now I think she should show
I don't know any move as possible
literally any move on the board what
what cuckoo pause what did you just do
are you serious you see what choku
Bosman you know what a game i mean i
think i think anybody could've won that
game literally there were like so many
situations there were either player
could've won yeah what a fantastic
finish I mean you were right the time
situation was the most important factor
here we saw so many blenders at the end
unfortunately often with time pressure
blasts Brady make the blender is the one
who loses yeah I think I mean I felt
that it's it's very weird though how
often times when you look at this game
someone saw an idea like three moves
after it was good like this pawn to e4
is hanging for I think three different
moves and choko bars did not take it any
of the first time so I was fine then at
the very end when it actually wasn't
good she did take the pawn so um yeah I
mean I think the game really came down
to the time situation I think if if
Joker bar has had more time at the end
she probably would have won that game as
opposed them both having one minute so
very tough game but there is still the
bracket so it's it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens for both
players well you're back we're joined
with both slicker and choco bars that
was such an up and down game Janet you
had the lead at the start you're up a
piece you're playing incredibly then you
got into some time pressure and started
making a couple more mistakes um do you
have any thoughts on that on how the
game went for you Janet
um as usual the same problem for me is
that I have a decent early and then
later on when it reaches to a mid game I
tried to like make even trades but then
I guess I don't see that it's even and
then it just slowly became more on
slickers favorite side yeah and then
time is always an issue because in my
past two games I lost because I didn't
take my time but now I feel like people
are saying I cook too much time so I
haven't been able to find that balance
yet and it's really frustrating well I
think that's something that definitely
comes more with experience it's really
hard to get it just right and a lot of
players have been struggling with that
so you know don't don't feel too bad
about it and flicker I mean I was an
incredible comeback you have awesome
fighting spirit there you plan that
checkmate in the end it was all planned
it was all planned I am you see like
force and said quote by quote if once
you become confident the overconfidence
will overconfident you so make any sense
no but but you know like it was it was
definitely plan like yeah I know II
tried to take one piece so I was like I
even asked a cha ok I said she's gonna
keep taking trading ok and you did boy
I'm not sure if you noticed I was a few
polite points in the game where I move
my rock and you could have took me with
your pawn you met you there I'll be
honest I really I'm not gonna lie just
say I don't know how I won that game I
don't know you know I'm just new ok
don't feel too good about feeding me
slicker all right I'm new and in a month
rematch me and I will beat you I just
need more experience and then we'll have
a rap battle because I heard your rap
earlier about me yeah that was a bit
weird well you know the the rematch
won't happen ok you're gonna lose the
first round
cause you are zero you stay like that
you ain't going free you're gonna stick
out the quote files
you're gonna lose please guys put me up
against two please
for when I get a win and then I can
shove this in your face next time you
yeah okay yeah I mean I'm trying to stay
calm but you don't go you don't good you
don't good listen ye you don't alright
well you just gonna you ain't gonna beat
me okay these guys these like fossum
name and all that these guys are little
kids all right yes but still you know
she's got a little kids mother this this
one is for the little kids to go up you
know but the the consultation brackets
that's where the big boys go - all right
ear up a father xqc bond like a man and
me okay the whole you know wait that's
it and then you get you guys are just
gonna get this I knew I was gonna win
boy I was sweating I was I was I was
struggling I didn't know what to do at
that point I was I was like she might
win she we use doing some steep sorry I
didn't use doing some silly weird moves
he's doing some weird moves I used
moving the horse any reason what were
you doing he told you okay no one told
me don't worry stuff but I was moving my
horse because I just felt like I would
[Laughter]
ya need to play well I love all people
I'd say you like compared to Ludwig yeah
all right I don't want to be too
disrespectful because it's like it's
like 11 o'clock and
twenty past eleven you know mama Baba's
sleeping right now so you know I don't
enforce all my rage towards taco bus
plus I don't want to my myriad cuz my
mic my headset is not working properly
yeah I can hear you
yeah so like I don't know I don't know
what else to say easy game
I suppose I'm kind of curious like
slicker your there's a very good
possibility that you're gonna have to go
up against uh against Ludwig in the in
the bracket now you guys played this
caught this this fun game I think a
couple days ago but there is a good
chance you'll play him in the bracket
are you looking forward to that rematch
um I'm looking forward to anyone to be
honest fiercely or whatever this might
just put me up against someone first
easy so I can at least get more money
like if I'm against a who Swift I don't
know and who's up Who am I gonna be up
against is slicker few cynic you guys
make the game so wait why do you guys
profusely and xqc group if they grew up
in being lazy group so if it's Ludwig I
don't mind I don't care who iversity and
I just wanna win this finals and get
that cash you know hmm
fighting words go back hopefully you do
it yeah thank you man I love you guys
mom hurry wait can you train me bro
cuz you ain't trained me yet yeah I
definitely can help you out yeah for
sure
do I look like a guy that needs training
haircut well I mean I'm also wearing
your your team that's I'm talking about
awesome talk to Nevada did you say did
you vouch for me at the start
oh not not exactly not exactly because
your coach has been taking the owls so I
had a feeling he was gonna bring you the
bad karma again today but luckily you
you pulled through despite having some
issues at the start of the game but it
was impressive though the way you kept
it together when you were much worse
than the game I thought was was and oh
yeah I know I I know even the point when
she moved the rook at the end down oh my
god come on Coco's chick stuffer why'd
you do that
like keep it away yeah but I'm talking
about the end like when when they're
choked and you meet look look look do a
plate mine it was fun it was fun month
thank you for the game boys I mean guys
oh thank you slicker and in jannat you
did have a really nice comeback slicker
that was nice to watch and Janet you
played very well you got the extra piece
I think it's just a matter of getting
more comfortable with the time situation
and trying to play a bit more accurately
when you're in time pressure but that's
something that everyone has trouble with
I think this game really could have gone
either way so thank you both for being
here and good luck in the future thank
you
[Music]